أريد أن ألعب من أجلك بعض مقاطع الفيديو الجديدة
التي ظهرت في المقدمة والتي أعلم
أنها لفتت انتباهك أيضًا ، كما
يمكنك رؤيتها هنا على شاشتك
لكل شخص في المنزل ، ويبدو أنها تظهر
القوات الروسية تتعرض للهجوم
وفي محاولتهم المحمومة  يمكنك الهروب من
خط النار ،
يمكنك رؤية العديد من الجنود يتراكمون على
السطح الخارجي لمركبة عسكرية
تبتعد فيها الدبابة ، وما
تراه هناك يسقط على
جانب الطريق ، أعني أنه لا يمكن لـ CNN
التحقق بشكل مستقل من  فيديو ولكن في
رؤية هذا العام ، ما الذي تراه هنا
جيدًا ، فأنت تعرض المقطع بالكامل
الآن وترى جنودًا غير منضبطين
عبر اللوحة منذ
البداية قفزوا على BTR
بدون زي موحد ، وقد تم
إعفاء خوذهم  بعضهم
يرتدي قبعات بيسبول في الخلف ، ويقومون
بتسليم قذائف الهاون إلى برج
هذه السيارة ، آه إنهم تعلمون أنك
تسمع صوت الجنزير الذي يقوله القائد ،
ابحث عن مكان تعلق به  جنود
يقولون إنني لا أعرف أين يمكنني تعليق
السيارة على متنها ، فأنت ترى جنودًا
يفقدون خوذتهم أثناء تحليقها على
الطريق ، ولا يوجد طيار إلى
الخوذة التي انفجرت للتو ، ولا يوجد
طيار في هذه السيارة ينطلقون
فجأة  في الخندق ربما لأن
بعض هؤلاء الجنود الموجودين
فوق المركبات يحجبون
رؤية السائق ، إنها مجرد كوميديا
للخطأ كيت أعني أن هذه هي
الأشياء التي يبحث عنها الجنود في
حشد فوضوي غير منضبط وليس مجموعة  من
الجنود وهذا مجرد
تمثيل لما رأيناه في قوة غير مدربة
منذ البداية حيث
أنا متأكد في هذه الحالة أن بعض الجنود
أصيبوا بجروح بالغة أو ربما
قتلوا عندما انقلبت تلك السيارة
وكان ذلك لمجرد  إنهم لا يعرفون
كيفية أداء أنواع المهارات
المتوقعة من الجنود في ساحة المعركة
، والحمد لله أن القوة الأوكرانية
أكثر انضباطًا ، فلديهم نواة ضابط صف
تفرض المعايير.  ds والشيء الأساسي
هو أن الشتاء قادم حيث
تحدثنا عن أنه الآن تبلغ درجة الحرارة 38
درجة في كييف ، الجو بارد ،
وما زلنا في نوفمبر ، يجب تطبيق نوع
الانضباط المطلوب في القوة الآن
من قبل ncos  الروس
ليس لديهم هذا
الانضباط وسيعانون خلال هذا الشتاء أكثر
من القوة الأوكرانية على ما أعتقد